Commonly referred to as the rock star
physicist has been described as the
natural successor for BBC scientific
programming by both David attenborough
and Patrick Moore on by some as
England's equivalent to Neil degrasse
Tyson.
That must feel good,
does it if you're a scientist to be
described in that way.
Not by me,
by David attenborough and I was there
when he.
When he said it,
actually I was presenting him with an
award.
It was a radio times awards I think as I
presented him with the,
with the award and he stood up to the
microphone and then said,
if I had a torch,
should I pass it to you?
And then went and sat down again.
And of course there's nothing you can
say,
and I've thought about it since the.
The real answer is that the Columbia
successor in the way that can't be a
successor to Neil Armstrong because
David attenborough was the.
He invented the form really naturally be
documentary was pioneered by him.
So he's the first and still the best.
If you watched blue planet two,
that he's still making groundbreaking
documentaries.
So there will ever be another one that
is 50 years of natural history,
possibly what he's referring to in terms
of succession is a sort of
popularization and humanization.
If it could be such word of data and
information that can have previously
been somewhat esoteric and inaccessible.
And uh,
I suppose that must be one aspect of
your work that's difficult to quantify.
Your personal charisma,
your particular success.
Is that something that you have as much
impact on you psychologically?
Well,
I mean the first thing is humanization
is a good word actually because I think
that science is,
I mean,
what is it?
It's,
it's the study of nature.
So.
And it's,
it's a humble pursuit.
It's about just looking at essentially
small things and asking very simple
questions.
I'm a childlike questions now,
why is the sky blue?
Why is that leaf green?
And one of those little points of light
in the sky.
And so the things we find out a demand I
think demand the response there,
especially when talking about cosmology,
you know,
we're talking about the size and scale
and origin of the university theater
return or questions.
And so I think they demand the human
response and that's the thing that I've
always felt I've went out when I was
little dude,
dude,
astronomy,
which is looking up at the sky,
the feelings that you get from looking
at those points of light and
understanding they were the worlds and
understand how far they are away.
And so on.
Our,
um,
our deep and challenging feelings.
I think people miss that a lot.
People think of science as the thing you
do in the lab with some batteries in
school.
You know that science is a switch,
not questions about the origin of the
universe itself.
I think you're precisely correct that
actually we don't spend enough time
analyzing that feeling and to continue
the
comparison between yourself and David
out and borrow what one sense is,
is that he has a deep love of the
subject and it means something to him
and he wants people to understand it.
And that's what you've just described,
is that when you are for you,
the study of the cosmos is not about
mathematics and relationships between
physical phenomena.
Abstract from the emotion,
but very much as if somehow the
experience of that emotion or the
realization of that motion or suddenly
the relationship between those emotions.
Could you explain that a little bit of.
Yeah,
right?
Yeah.
I think.
I think that signed the act of doing
science is an emotional response to
nature and you said you see it with
David attenborough.
He loves life on earth.
That living things he finds them
fascinating,
has a connection to them,
understands that the idea that we are
part of one unbroken chain of life,
stretching back 4 billion years is a
powerful idea.
When I always think that you know when,
when you look a blade of grass in the
pavement,
probably sticking up through the
concrete,
the,
the history of life on earth is written
into that thing.
So the more,
the more you understand them,
the more you think about the things that
you're looking at.
The more powerful the experiences and
the more challenging the thoughts are in
that sentence.
The,
the fact that in order to understand the
blade of grass,
you have to understand the history of
life on earth.
Four billion year timescales,
uh,
those,
I think a challenging ideas immediately
and,
and they're emotionally challenging
ideas.
So I think science is an emotional
response to the universe because you
become a scientist when you,
you latch onto an idea like that.
And so I want to know,
I want to know what the origin of life
was so I can understand the things that
I see
today.
So you see in the minutiae of life at
the continuum of nature and that,
that is,
uh,
through that aperture,
the most profound questions conceivable,
uh,
we have to imagine answers to them.
I think they all,
all the roads of inquiry leads to
profound ideas and not always actually
to the statement we don't know.
So we don't know yet if we ever will.
Uh,
how life began probably began on earth.
You know,
there are theories that it came the
called Panspermia that he began
somewhere else and then was brought here
by cometry.
Impact or asteroid is possible.
It's unlikely though,
but
sorry to interrupt you,
but is there any significance to those
theories?
Just philosophically,
I suppose that if life was at some point
in his stellar or an eclectic that it
interrupts the narrative of life
beginning of on at this point is they
are.
They are profound philosophical
implications.
Is it relevant and is there any reason
to believe it might be true?
I think it doesn't matter so
philosophically
because it had to begin someone because
we know the universe was hot and 13
point 8 billion years ago,
which is a thing we called the big bang
and we know that they wouldn't have been
any life around.
Then we just the physical conditions
with far too extreme,
so life began somewhere and the way I
like to look at it,
it,
it lets,
lets say began on earth.
It doesn't matter though.
It could have be going to Mars or
somewhere else,
but the arguments the same.
It means that geochemistry became
biochemistry.
So what happens somewhere most likely on
earth is that a dead planet,
but in planet with a hot core and
volcanoes and those things,
a chemical reactions happened in the
oceans which changed from geology and
geochemistry to biochemistry.
And that's a profound thing.
So it's.
The planet did almost certainly gave
birth to us,
which is quite a nice age.
It's an ancient philosophical idea.
Very Atlantic gave birth to us,
but that's very light,
light,
guyer idea.
I suppose that,
yeah,
that the mother earth in a very literal
fantastic.
It has to have certain.
What about the,
the distinction between a geo and bio,
uh,
a life.
Why?
Why is that so significant by one meter?
By what metric are we understanding life
if there was a meteorological system
that can produce life,
is that not in itself life?
Well,
yeah.
So it's almost a semantic distinction in
a way.
I mean,
you're right,
it still just chemistry.
And so when does Geo Chemistry become
biochemistry?
So the standard answer would be when
molecules begin to self replicate.
So that would be.
So information can be passed from
generation to generation.
Once you've got that,
then you have evolution,
wow,
and then you have live,
so you've got to have some physical,
chemical,
some molecule that can reproduce itself
and the inflammation in the structure of
the molecule is passed on to the copy
and once you've got that,
I think you basically got life guys
determined as biology.
We can see that as biochemistry,
self-replicate in molecules prior to
that.
It can't be tracked or understood in
that way.
If you've.
If you've got a system which can't pass
information on,
then you can't have evolution and if you
can't have evolution,
you can't get the life that we see today
and it might.
You can't even get single celled
organisms because they are very
complicated bits of chemistry and the
key thing is how did chemistry gets so
complicated and I think the key to that
is that you get something that can pass
information so you don't lose
information.
You add the information from generation
to generation.
Physical risks.
This distinction between geological
life,
biological life seems contingent on its
relationship with us as the observer and
how we narrate that transition.
As you said,
it's almost a semantic distinction as it
is in both forms.
It is chemistry,
is it not possible that our role as
observer and the way that we narrate
information is the true determinant as
opposed
to the observable and obviously
extremely significant fact that cells
are now self replicating to us as
observers.
That's extremely significant but only
pops to us as observers given in the
great scope of 13 point 8 billion years.
All this happening is some great,
uh,
Aria of creation.
It's a really important point.
I think it,
you're talking about the value of
consciousness in the universe,
the value of civilizations,
and we know of one place in the universe
where there in Richard fineman words,
atoms that can contemplate atoms.
That's what we are now.
And that to me is that we are the most
valuable structures that we know of in
the universe.
Now,
when I say that,
sometimes people get very,
you know,
people are liable to say things.
I owe human to damaging the planet and
we're better off without them.
This is nonsense,
right?
The point is,
the most remarkable thing about our
physical universe is that there are
places where atoms can contemplate atoms
at one place that we know of,
and that might be.
We might be quite rare.
We don't know.
We've looked a bit and we've seen no
sign of anyone else.
We we.
It's called the great silence.
Astronomers call it the great silence
because we listened with radio
telescopes and we look out into space,
see no sign of any other civilizations
and so it could be quite a lonely
existence that we have here,
but therefore very valuable indeed.
Whilst I understand the necessity for
science as the study of nature to be
based on evidence,
in fact indeed that is its essence.
That is its modus operandi.
That is what defines it does not the
requirement that until there is
evidence,
we stay with the assumption that there
isn't.
Even though we don't know is
parenthesized.
Doesn't that lead to a sort of.
Do you not think that somehow
facilitates the dogmatic aspect of
science,
which has meant that it's sort of
science has become somewhat doctrinaire
and informative of areas beyond the
humble study of nature and it's becoming
fact,
a kind of ideology that leads to
materialism,
rationalism and all of the other things
that are on that particular evolutionary
chain?
I,
I hope not because it shouldn't,
it shouldn't,
but it sounds.
I'm just talking about great scientists.
I've just not been able to drink tea
properly.
Good professor.
Don't put that in your nose if you're
inhaling into your lungs.
Know I've read about that because it's
got to go straight down into the tummy,
but I think there's and lemonade and
made it a later point.
I think the science itself,
it is,
it's,
it's humble in the sense that it's about
paying attention to small things and
that's it.
So you think about it.
An example would be Einstein's theory of
general relativity,
which is the framework within which we
do cosmology,
which is the study of the universe.
So these are grandiose aimed,
you know,
we talked about the origin and evolution
of the universe.
That's a big idea,
but Einstein's theory of general
relativity was conceived as a theory of
gravity,
which is a theory of how things move
around in the vicinity of the earth.
And that's it.
So it's talking about if you throw a
ball in the air,
what happens to it now?
It perhaps had the moon goes around the
earth or the earth goes around the sun.
It became a theory of the structure,
the large scale structure of the
universe afterwards.
And I think that's really crucial.
There are very few scientists who try to
begin by saying,
I am going to answer the great
questions.
I want the theory of everything.
I want to understand the whole universe
that is not the road to wisdom.
Actually in science,
the roadster,
roadster,
wisdom and knowledge.
Well,
knowledge first and then wisdom is by
paying attention to small things.
And then what we find.
I think because the universe appears to
be simple at its very basic level,
there are laws of nature that seemed to
be accessible to us when we seem to be
able to understand and there are very
few of them.
Then virtually all road roads of inquiry
lead you to,
if you followed them to some depth to
some,
well the fundamental,
but I wouldn't call them truth because
we have to say that we don't have the
full set of fundamental laws of nature.
We certainly know that.
So the laws that we have at the moment
are incomplete now.
Then they break down in certain
situations.
For example,
Einstein's theory doesn't work at the
center of a black hole or the origin of
the universe.
So we don't have the theoretical tools
to talk about what happens right in the
middle of a black hole,
for example.
So it was more the observation of a
conditional pattern as opposed to an
absolute truth because we don't know
what's on the reverse side of that
pattern.
Is it,
do you think it would be there?
They could just be models.
They are going to send models,
which,
uh,
of the way that reality works.
What about mask?
I'm like,
we're with the thing that you said about
Oppenheimer,
uh,
earlier.
I was very intrigued by Oppenheimer.
You said that it was his discoveries
that lead to,
well,
he ran the Manhattan project so,
and he became haunted by it as many
people.
Did you know,
he,
I think he felt that the first bomb on
Hiroshima was so horrific,
but almost justifiable in the sense that
it was a act to end the war.
The second one on Nagasaki,
I think he thought which gratuitous and
he felt the power that scientists and
engineers had given to politicians were
so great that the politicians wouldn't
be able to handle it,
wouldn't be able to control it.
And he,
he actually said in the 19 fifties that
he was surprised that we were still
here,
as did many.
Richard Feynman oil mentioned also
worked on the Manhattan project and he
said he was very surprised that we were
here in the mid 19 fifties.
He thought that we would not control
this power and,
but actually we have a remarkably up to
so you know,
what,
70 years after we got that power,
we were still here,
so we haven't used it again.
Um,
but I think that,
yeah,
that,
that oftentimes felt that there are
great lessons for the way that we run
society in the approach,
the scientific approach which was abide
by analogy almost.
So these ideas that I've spoke about
already that we don't have absolute
truth in science and we don't think we
know anything for certain and we are
humble with the way that we approach
nature and crucially that our opinion
counts for nothing in the face of
nature.
If we're,
we can be shown to be wrong.
And,
and we should be delighted when we shown
to be wrong because it means we've
learned something and that's at the
heart of the scientific and Debra and he
felt those things could be translated
from science to politics and the way
that we run societies.
And then if we do that,
we would have the wisdom to control the
power.
This is a very beautiful ideology.
Isn't it?
And it's sort of not underwritten by,
as you say.
I like the idea of approaching nature
with humility,
with grace,
with an understanding of our own
limitations seems to me like a,
a spiritual doctrine that should be used
in precisely in politics,
in domestic,
familial life.
This is sort of,
for me,
that is almost a universal idea that we
approach nature up with love and
compassion because obviously what I was
very curious about what the one of the
reasons I went to meet you for the
respect you enormously.
I respect what you've done and the depth
breadth of knowledge that you have and
the way that you've conveyed it is
awesome.
But I know that as a man of science that
you are.
I said Sova famously atheistic.
Is that right?
No,
no,
I don't think so.
I mean,
I,
first of all,
I reject the label because I think that
it's divisive and uh,
so I genuinely think that science does
not rule out the existence of a creator
by,
by definition,
because we don't know how the universe
began full stop.
That's it.
We don't know.
Right?
We have a theory of what might've
happened before,
the Big Bang theory called inflation,
which says that the universe was still
around but doing something else,
but we still left with the question.
How did that start?
How did the universe have a beginning
and if so,
how did it begin?
The entries?
We don't know.
Full Stop.
So you can't read it from a scientific
perspective.
It is wrong to say that science has
anything to say at all about the,
the,
the nature of a,
of a creator or the,
the,
the can be that because we don't know.
That's all I say is that I don't
personally have any faith.
I'd have a personal faith.
Now we can dig into that.
Do you mean faith as in preexisting
ideological structure that you use as a
framework for your understanding of
reality or do you mean faith as sort of
an inward that there is beauty and great
because when you said that humility and
all that,
that sounded like a faithful.
Yeah,
so,
so I suppose it depends and you could
talk about this more actually,
how,
what,
how you define the word.
I mean to me all,
I mean when I say that is I don't have a
religion that I adhere to.
I don't,
I do not know what the origin of the
laws of nature is and,
and that that's enough for me.
Yeah.
I don't really.
I don't feel compelled.
I,
I'd love to know,
but I don't feel compelled to go further
than the statement that I don't know.
And I think that's certainly one of my
books.
That's one of the greatest of mysteries.
We are part of the greatest mysteries
and for me that's enough.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
There's a very beautiful humility in
that.
It's wonderful because what I was gonna
say is that like that all I do have
faith and if I,
if I have to sort of unpack it and I'll
move for us to continue our
conversation.
What I'm fascinated by perennialism and
patterns that are found consistently
throughout human mythologies.
They're dislocated geographically that
seemed to have universal themes and
ideas and that I later discovered to
have relationships that can,
to some degree be described by science,
by the language of science and their
spirit of science,
particularly as you describe it with
such a,
um,
what would I say?
Spirit of love egg for example.
It was curious to me that oppenheimer as
I understand and can remember I'm in
dangerous territory and anytime I step
towards science review and never cited
to me like the [inaudible],
I think he quoted the back of our gator
at the point that the,
um,
the of those tests,
those nuclear tests and indeed buddy,
you know,
attacks is it.
I am become death.
The destroyer of worlds.
Yeah.
And for me that there's something,
what is that they're in like,
you know,
this is the thing I can't get my head
around and this is gcse stuff.
Is that campaign within the,
as it was then the,
you know,
one of the smallest components of our
physical reality with the capacity for
such enormous destruction that there's
inconceivable energy with health like
that.
I mean like that one there.
The reason is I'm curious about it is
because there are influences in
religious scripture that seemed to be
trying to describe that,
that within the infantile and Somali
small there is great power that there is
limitless,
that all things were endowed with
consciousness.
These are the sort of like when I
approach religion,
I don't sort of pick one particular book
and God right on with these guys and and
anyone who's not with it,
I'd like to see them killed.
Luckily it's much more like,
oh my God,
they seem to be describing stuff without
the language,
without the language or the capacity.
A very sort of somewhat trite example
when dealing with her mind such as yours
would be the,
you know,
the recent discovery of the benefits of
mindfulness,
mindfulness and meditation for Millennia
have been spoken of as valuable for the
human condition to have an access to an
aspect of your own consciousness.
That's precisely not about rationalism
and materialism,
but it's about access to perhaps the
systems that very kindly run your
kidneys for you and all of that.
And so when that's discovered,
demonstrable,
a,
um,
valuable,
it becomes popularized or underwritten
by dogma excellence at least,
but there were communities and
ideologies that knew that these
technologies were powerful without the
apparatus we had.
And I think contained throughout
scripture,
people talking about oneness,
unity,
respect for nature,
the nature of the soul,
the nature of consciousness.
And it's only from,
for me,
whether it's from a scientific
background or religious background is
only when it becomes doctrinal or people
go,
this is definitely the answer.
Fuck you.
That it becomes problematic.
Yeah.
And I think,
I mean,
so I would say that I don't think the,
I think the way to access,
um,
the way to build models about the way
that nature works is to observe nature,
right?
Which is essentially the scientific
method.
You observed nature,
you come up with some model,
you test it,
and if it doesn't agree with what you
see,
then it's wrong when you throw it away
or you that.
So I suppose really if you think about
the human condition for many thousands
of years from the time when we first had
such a thing,
it's about,
it's a responds to nature to everything
about being human is about responding to
nature.
So I would be surprised if if people
didn't in that,
in those responses that they have,
didn't,
didn't observe things,
patterns and discover things that you
know you don't need.
You don't need modern science to allow
you to discover the.
There's a regularity in the passage of
the seasons,
for example,
because you see it.
It's most of what it means to be human.
So I'm not surprised that the.
And also as you say,
in terms of how to exist as as a,
as a human being,
than the scientists not going to tell
you that actually it can tell you,
well,
it will be better review a little bit
less fat,
but it's not going to tell you about how
to be content and happy.
What would it does is I think provides a
framework of.
I'm not truth,
I don't like the word truth,
but I'm trying to get at because we can
always.
We can always discover things a
different way,
but it provides you a framework.
For example,
it says,
well,
the earth goes around the sun now and it
tells us that there are a hundred
billion stars in the Milky Way Galaxy.
Brilliant.
That's one of 2 trillion galaxies in the
observable universe getting heavy now,
but that's challenging,
isn't it?
But then what?
What,
what?
What are we to make of that humility.
Let listeners and and I think that's one
of the most interesting things that we
are.
We discovered that we are at it
physically and insignificant speck in
the universe,
so you can't argue with otherwise.
There are 2 trillion galaxies in a bit
we can see,
but at the same time there's the idea
that consciousness at contemplating
atoms might be very rare and therefore
we can be valuable and insignificant at
the same time.
And this is what Oppenheimer meant by
what?
In his lectures.
I spoke about them not on the podcast
actually running this show earlier that
he talks about an idea called
complementarity,
which comes from.
It came from the early quantum mechanics
studies.
People are Niels Bohr and others and it
is actually,
it comes from eastern philosophy.
I think this idea that you have to hold
mutually contradictory,
apparently mutually contradictory ideas
in your head.
You have to in order to get a full
picture of reality,
and that's true in interpreting quantum
mechanics and what he said is what
you've already referred to is that
people have known this for a long time,
that you.
You also have to do it to understand the
human condition run society and it's a
very good example of how science and
deeper philosophical thinking.
Intersex.
Yes.
That's.
That's fascinating and beautiful because
I suppose what's implicit in that are
quite fundamental ideas around
objectivity and subjectivity.
The inner and outer world and the way
that they relate and the a is out out
our tendency to regard that the world
from,
from an individualistic perspective,
Po lead potentially to quite a lot of
problems.
One of the things I'm very curious
about,
and I know that your rationalism reason
and what's demonstrable is hugely
significant and important,
but what fascinates me is that it seems
that certainly in earlier times people
were relating to their own consciousness
in ways that somewhat define our
rational understanding.
People were having sort of yoga
meditative trips and now people like you
know,
for ios going pio,
interesting romantic plants that people
have always used,
have different experiences within
consciousness that tackle this sort of
ideas that you're saying science deals
with now imperiously and rationally
unnecessarily,
but the fact that there might be other
avenues to know.
Again,
I will be reluctant to use a word as
absolute truth,
but there are different avenues to
understanding different avenues to
incite fascinates me with the
construction of mythologies.
As you said,
man is continually relating to his own
environment,
shaping,
shaped by his environment.
The basis of.
Well,
one of the bases I'm sure over evolution
is that the way that we relate to
external conditions and of course those
conditions very and for political
couches that were early adopters of
agriculture,
have myths that demonstrate that where
God to sacrificed and put in the ground
and hunt SSR is as tend to be more
individualistic.
They know the myths evolve to represent
natural circumstance,
demonstrable demonstratively,
but what I'm interested in,
one of the things I'm interested in,
professor,
is how can we use,
as we've just touched upon with that
idea that opened said that itself echoed
a spiritual,
how can we use what we learn in science
to inform our societies in bloody
difficult times politically and
globally?
What values can we extract?
I'll answer that and then going to go
back to something you said we should
vote.
Routes to.
Insight for thought was really
interesting because the answer that
question directly is that oftentime
appointed.
I said it'd be think about political
philosophy,
the way that we organize our society.
So you might think that they're mutually
contradictory axiom,
so for example,
one could be a freedom of the
individual.
If you're a libertarian,
extreme libertarian,
you think that individual freedom is the
most important thing and you might be
prepared to compromise a bit and build
something in of have a society with.
Ultimately you're talking about freedom
as the base,
the basis,
whereas if you're on the,
if you're a communist or further to the
left,
you might be thinking that society is
all that matters and you might
reluctantly build a bit of individual
freedom in and will often.
Jaime was saying when this idea of
complementarity is the two ideas of
freedom and society are inextricably
linked,
they feed off each other.
They are both necessary for deal.
That's who exist,
so you can't have freedom without a
society and you can't have a society
without freedom and it's just the idea
that you don't start saying,
Oh yeah,
I'm a conservative.
I am a Marxist,
I am,
or whatever.
You have to understand that human
society and its interaction with
individualities very complicated and you
need to.
You need to understand.
You need to be comfortable with holding
those two ideas.
We called them orthogonal in physics at
right angles,
the mutually contradictory ideas.
I'm drawing,
drawing a little as good,
orthogonal 90 degrees to each other.
You have to hold both of them in your
head and be comfortable and understand
that you need them both to get a full
sure thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis.
There's another spiritual ideas
contradictory and you have to do it in,
in understanding quantum mechanics,
and that's the great thing because
nature forces you to think like that,
so it's no longer optional animas key
point,
yes,
so you're trained,
you're forced to think in that way,
and that's very valuable.
Yes,
but also say Brian,
that the way that semantics and these
systems of taxonomy actually operate is
a word like freedom is determined by the
powerful.
So freedom ultimately becomes in where
we can say in our society,
freedom within limits,
and ultimately freedom to consume,
freedom to behave in accordance with
these ideologies.
This is what freedom means.
When political figures talk about they
hate our freedoms or they're attacking
our freedoms,
wha wha.
What they mean by freedom is often
indicated by the maxims they spout.
When in crises,
Eg go out and shop after nine slash 11
or there is no such thing as society
from Margaret Thatcher.
These like these sort of a momentary
fishes with ever fruit,
which we can glance what they mean.
What is the state,
what it,
what is their truth?
Because like we were discussing earlier
in my summer intentionally to aft radio
show.
Um,
the,
um.
Oh God,
no,
I forgot what I was saying there.
Sometimes I'll come.
I was operating on a level that was.
Wow.
Well you said that you've given examples
of people who are convinced that they
are right now is the point.
Yeah.
Certainty.
You said beware of people that are
served and I think that,
you know,
we're really,
if you think about what a free society
is,
that it means that there's a spectrum of
viewpoints on every issue.
And so you can imagine,
I'd call it a distribution with the
mathematics recall the tails of the
distribution,
which are the bits at the end.
So most people might believe this stuff
in the middle,
but there are people on either side that
believe other things.
And if you have to,
by definition in a free society,
find yourself occasionally at odds with
the majority.
That is a signal that you live in a free
society and you should celebrate it.
And I think that the key lesson for me
from,
from just thinking rather more
scientifically about things,
is that is to understand that when you
find yourselves in disagreement with
other people,
it is.
It is a signal of a healthy democracy in
a healthy society and you should
celebrate every time you find you're an
outlier.
You should be waving a flag.
You shouldn't be running down the street
cheering going,
I don't live in North Korea.
That's what you should be.
And that has been lost.
You do live in North Korea.
Which case don't run down the flag if
you're listening to this,
should not create.
But I think we've lost that.
You see on Yammer,
we both,
we're both on twitter and we see that
the polarization of debates means that
people are just not thinking.
They're not stopping and thinking the
fact that this person is saying
something with which I disagree,
signals to me that our societies healthy
and the moment that nobody's saying
things that I disagree with is the
moment you should actually then you
should leave the country and run.
Don't you think that what we're
witnessing now is the time of
foreclosure around discourse,
that more and more things are becoming
to booth,
that there's a reemergence of censure
and the Internet,
as you just indicated,
is a very good example of that.
These are the things that are unsayable.
Furthermore,
don't you think that the art,
we have to say that there are
ideologies.
Ideals are being said.
There is such a thing as power.
We're not living in a society that's
constantly fluctuating and according to
the will of the majority,
were living in a democracy where the
function of democracy is to limit the
capacity of people to impact its
objectives.
And the one of the problems of
globalization is that it has meant the
establishment of a.
they're not subject to sort of national,
any kind of a regional law by.
They seem to live in a kind of what I
would say,
a sort of a rarefied protected space
that and what you've seen with the
brexit votes and I,
I don't think it's the right route at
all.
I mean,
I,
I think I'm a great fan of the European
Union.
However,
what you've seen with the brexit vote is
extremely positive in the sense you're
talking because what you've seen is a,
a statement by the majority of people in
the country that they reject the status
quo.
Sure.
And I think they have done it.
They have rejected the status quo.
A prime minister resigned.
There's now a absolute flux in politics
and,
and so I think that we.
Brian,
I think we have to note two things here.
One,
it's a massive anomaly.
It doesn't happen very often.
Stuff like brexit.
That's why everyone's wearing themselves
and all giggly and excited about that.
Brexit in itself was an emotional
reaction or rational reaction.
People won't go more because I want to
see these trade laws or emotions,
but it showed you that the status quo
can be overturned in a democracy because
at the moment we don't have this.
I would say within certain guidelines,
I don't think,
you know,
when's the vote for now we're going to
tax corporations at this rate.
Now we're going to,
oh,
uh,
this is how we want to pay mortgages.
This is how we want our societies.
You can argue that it may be that we
see,
for example,
Jeremy Corbyn is prime minister,
which would have been absolutely
unthinkable and two years ago,
and if he does become prime industry
will be as a result of the brexit vote,
that that will be the route that a more
radical politician managed it.
That's how a radical politician will
have got into number 10.
Now,
I,
I'm,
I think brexit is a mistake because I
think that it,
that the people that voted to,
uh,
to challenge the status quo are going to
suffer the most from this and the
removal of the freedoms that we have to
move around Europe.
Europe,
the removable of access to single
market,
I was thinking,
so I think actually it's the wrong
solution.
Possibly,
unless they are interested in
democratically that it can.
It can
still happen unless it does lead to a
left wing government who use it as an
opportunity to create new legislation
around the behavior of transnational
corporations,
different taxation or something.
Hey,
you know there is.
I was talking to someone in here
recently about like a possible left wing
outcome for Europe.
I don't.
We dragged down at bloody brexit
quagmire when a man who understands the
bleeding.
I didn't plan to talk about that,
but I think it's a good demonstration
what you're talking about it you could
see as a healthy attack on the status
quo.
You could say,
I don't think it'll have that result,
but
no,
I mean the fact that it's an anomaly is
what concerns me and the fact that we
lower the threshold of what's acceptable
for democracy.
We've got democracy once in a while.
We can have a Miss God.
Misguided carnival of disruption instead
of democracy is why don't we control our
communities and controlled so that the
most vulnerable people have access to
power.
That's democracy.
If it's not,
that is not democracy is a piece of
theater and like I don't settle for
that.
Do you remember like
because of you and I,
we talked a little bit about because you
were very keen to encourage young people
to a point where I was saying it's
pointless and like it was a sort of an
intern because I,
I sense that you and I have a lot more
in common ideologically.
Then we have the separation even though
you are a scientist and I'm a religious
maniac and you often pro democracy and
I'm proud mass decentralization and
disillusion of power where possible,
you know,
but I feel that we're both driven by the
idea that we're essentially optimistic
is what I would say about you.
You seem like an optimistic man.
Yeah,
and you have to be.
Because we go back to what we were
talking about earlier about the value of
this place,
the earth and I think one of the.
If I could,
if there's one message that I would like
people to take away from anything that I
do is to is to value this place and
it's.
That's not some kind of like a sort of
hippy type thing.
Is it just based on the observation,
the,
the complexity of life on earth?
It may well be.
It may make us quite a unit.
We can be unique in a galaxy,
for example.
I don't think.
I'm sure there'll be other civilizations
out there in the billions of galaxies in
the universe,
but it could be that the average is that
there's about roughly one civilizations
per galaxy at any one time,
and imagine that Arthur c Clarke once
famously said that there are two
options.
Either we are alone or we're not in both
a terrifying,
but I think we need to proceed on the
basis that we are now an imagine.
If people thought about that,
which is just a matter of perspective.
If people thought actually that if we
decided to have a nuclear war tomorrow
accidentally perhaps and destroyed
intelligent life on the planets,
it may be that we destroy meaning in the
galaxy and meaning I use advisedly
because if you think about it,
meaning obviously exists in the universe
because it means something to us,
so there are collections of atoms that
somehow of of the property of meaning as
emerged.
It means something to us.
If we go,
then there will be no meaning in this
corner of the university.
Meaning is local and it's temporary and
I think accepting that but by which I
mean it it had in your head,
but when I say I think it's global way
though,
in a way it's irrelevant whether there
are other civilizations or this one's
unique in empirically.
I mean it's up to us.
It doesn't matter.
I like it.
Even life is beautiful.
Life is beautiful.
Whether or not someone's over there
having a beautiful time,
to me sort of irrelevant and also terms
such as local and ton portal,
a highly subjective terms as we have
already established that refer to
patterns themselves that exist within a
context and our consciousness relates
only to that context,
so the meaning that emerge.
Is it like,
you know,
whatever this thing is that transition
from online to live for various
gradients,
geological to biological,
whatever proceeded and whatever follows
that meaning is one of its components.
It's.
It exists as organically as trees.
Yeah.
Well physicists are.
Some scientists refer to as an emergent
property which is something that emerges
from some more fundamental structure and
then this is probably the difference
between us.
I ask you a question because because I
think that the great challenge of human
existence is to come to terms with the
fact that the meaning exists,
but it is,
as I said,
it's local in the sense that it's not
universal and I think that's the
difference.
If I was to define the difference
between a religious person or a non
religious,
I would say that it's a question to you,
but I would say that religion is
searching for global meaning and I think
it's local and I think there will come a
time in the life of the universe when
there is no meaning left because I think
that as far as they were approaching it
won't mean.
I think that's what I think though.
That's my truck.
That's precisely the problem is that
material materialism and rationalism
lead to individualism,
capitalism and consumerism.
We can see in real time what it leads to
politically and socially.
I mean more brutal than that though.
I mean the in the far future of the
universe.
There won't be any sons left shining,
so there won't be any atoms that can
contemplate at of course the universe.
I understand that and that is an
enormous thing to say,
Brian and and I've got absolutely no
bloody kit to argue with prince.
What does it mean to you?
You actually graduate.
What does it.
What do you feel like?
If I say there will come a time in the
future when there is no consciousness in
the universe and so,
so all possibility of meaning has gone,
but the universe will still be there.
I would say that within my philosophy,
consciousness and matter have the
reverse relationship too.
In yours.
I believe that emerges from
consciousness,
not vice versa,
so even where the astrophysical context
or in evolves.
As you know,
brilliant men such as yourself and your
predecessors have demonstrated that will
happen.
That to me is essentially irrelevant
because it's just part of the cosmic
ballet.
Continuing within the framework of
consciousness,
and I underwrite this of course,
speculative lake,
like all theories that are that bookend
creation it speculative as anybody
else's,
but for me in the proceeding,
the Big Bang there is consciousness
consciousness that is not individualized
consciousness.
There's no expressed through matter and
this is not something that I would
narrativize or used to underwrite or
support any particular ideology.
It's not like in our consciousness for
white people or a consciousness for
Muslims,
pure consciousness expressing itself
through Mata and that these patterns and
habits that are so beautifully
delineated,
these rules that discovered with these
rules that Herman Melville describes as
all human sciences,
but passing fables as we discover what
lies beyond them,
like these are an expression of this
consciousness,
so when eventually whatever
it is that exist instead of human beings
are consumed by the sun,
that doesn't matter to me because
individuation I believe is temporal.
The I am just part of a whole
consciousness temporarily occupying this
individual or I can't put it any better
than Bill Hicks.
We are one consciousness experiencing
itself subjectively and I would say that
the reason that geology becomes biology
is because the geology is conscious.
That consciousness is in all things and
the reason that we should love nature.
I love the earth and love one another is
because we are all one and there are
motifs for this through our culture.
Why are we moved by heroism?
Because a person's sacrificing
themselves for another why?
Because they know inadvertent commerce
on some deeper level that there is no
distinction between self and other.
This is mainly the greed of the senses,
dealing with physical information.
The experience are receives.
This is inside,
this is outside,
but ultimately in essentially those
distinctions are animalistic attempts to
understand limitless phenomena.
So that's why it doesn't matter to me.
Although I would say like you,
we have to regard these thing with love
because love in a very Christian sense,
actually let's.
Cs Lewis says,
you feel like you're rewarded when you
do a good thing and when you do a bad
thing,
you know that was bad,
so let's just go with that.
Be kind to one another.
Love one another.
Let people believe what they want to
believe.
So mine comes from that.
I'm not ashamed of the bits that sounded
a bit hippy because for me love is an
energy.
Love is a force,
and whilst it's difficult to quantify
and measure without it,
we are nothing.
I think
the only thing,
my view is it certainly bleaker,
right?
Pointing,
well,
but I think that actually the road see,
I would say that the road to wisdom is
is the most challenging question that I
face given the I'm saying that matter
and energy in the laws of nature exist
and then life emerges from them and then
they will come and sign when there's no
life so that that challenges you to say
what is the value then of life and given
that it is temporary and this emerges
and it will go away again and it will be
time when the universe is dark and there
is nothing left and I think that you get
some sort of delight from what I did
because I think in the sense that the
the piece is a human being I think comes
from finding your accommodation with
your temporary existence and I'm
learning that it's so.
The temporary nature of it to me makes
it more valuable is a fine as a tiny
amount of time is nothing in the light
of the universe.
A tiny amount of time when we not only
individually but as a human race can
exist and explore and love the universe.
It's a finite tiny amount of time and I
think
that's a much more difficult
accommodation to come to it,
but I think that's really.
I think that's what reality is and so
we've got to come to accommodation with,
but I think in that accommodation is the
way you learn to love the planets and
the people on it because you learned
that they are temporary and valuable and
franchise.
As long as it leads to that conclusion.
It sort of doesn't really matter.
But what we'll say is we've.
We've already acknowledged in the,
in this brief interview that our
understanding of the temporal framework
and the spatial framework of sort of
breaking down the more we examined them,
so why would we continue to use that
framework to conjecture billions of
years in the future when it's breaking
down?
Right now I'm in.
The way we do it by the way,
is to get to say it's a thing called a
freedom in equation,
which comes from general relativity from
Einstein's theory Republican in Nineteen
15.
And what Einstein's theory tells us is
that there is a a given thing which is
the fabric of the universe.
It's called space time.
So there's a thing and it doesn't tell
you where it came from,
it tells you there is such a thing,
but it does tell you how that thing
stretches and warps and deforms and
changes in response to the matter and
energy that are present in the
university.
So you can calculate,
given this amount of matter in this
amount of radiation and dark matter and
dark energy.
Now I've given all that stuff.
Now,
what will it do in the future?
What is the response of the fabric of
the universe to this stuff?
And that's what enables us to say with
some confidence that unless the new
physics that we don't understand it,
there might be,
but given what we know now,
the university is accelerating in its
expansion,
which we observe and he will come to a
point where we think it will just double
continually in size every 20 billion
years or so forever.
And we can make that prediction given
what we know now.
So there is,
that's the baseline sort of baseline
prediction is we are in the universe
that will end up in what's called an
exponential expansion,
doubling in size every 20 billion years
or so for ever because life cannot exist
indefinitely in such a universe,
of course not,
but that's not necessarily a linear
equation.
And reality may be fractal,
maybe spiral right at the basis of that
Theorem is the acceptance and we don't
know where it comes from,
where it's going and it infers that
it's,
you know,
as I know you've talked about a lot in
your programs is expanding into apparent
nothingness.
But then you see that our linguistic and
indeed psychological tools and
neurological thoughts I would imagine
from your perspective,
start to break down.
And so this is again where I sort of our
invite sort of faith say one thing.
It is a theory that is tested.
So is the theory that allows us to
build,
for example,
the satellite navigation system.
So quite I'm not having a go at bloody
Einstein or satellite navigation.
It does work within,
but it's a model.
But.
But Brian,
when you say satellite navigation
systems are fast,
fantastic,
though they are,
these are not tools that we're going to
use to measure the expanse of a dabbling
in millions of years.
This is a localized bit of information
that applies to us as corn or beans.
Just a quick explanation of how we know
it's expanding.
Oh,
is is simple observation that if you
look at the light from a distant galaxy
and then you find that it stretched so
quite literally mean the color changed.
It's called red shift.
So it's a lie as a wavelength and the
long wave.
So rather than the short wave lengths
are blue and what you find is light that
should have been blue because you see it
coming from a particular kind of answer
in that galaxy is actually now red.
And the explanation is that space has
been stretching during the time the
light has been traveling.
And what you find is the further the
galaxy is away,
the more delight you're stretched.
We should exactly what you'd expect.
If you live in an expanding universe and
by making those measurements she can
measure how fast the universe has been
expanding over billions of years and
then this is a sim,
no one could refute it and it's
absolutely beautiful and I only I know
that already and the reason I know who
it is because I've watched you explain
it elegantly and in a way that makes
sense to me and is meaningful to me,
but what I would add to that is we see
red,
we see blue.
We somehow within our minds experience
rate,
we experienced blue,
we have eyes,
we have senses.
We live in this realm where something is
experiencing something and like you
said,
atoms experiencing other atoms.
Now what we have to continually
acknowledges that there is a finite
ability to understand information.
There is evidently limitless
information.
At some point we're going to hit a wall
and you know,
continue the war and what exists beyond
that,
his theories,
conjecture,
imagination,
and it's curious to me that is steeped
in our theological history.
There were people speculating in similar
ways and reaching similar conclusions.
Of course,
no one can accurately say that's because
space is stretching,
so you experienced read is different
because why you've traveled different
for the different density of spite and
people aren't saying stuff like that,
but people are speculating and trying to
understand the phenomena of
limitlessness
reminded me.
Yeah,
and you remind about something you said
earlier site which is this,
which is the.
So I would say that I would.
I would disagree with you in a sense in
that the finding out the way that nature
works,
I think is the is is is only done
through what we might loosely call the
scientific method,
right?
Which is which is making observations
and building theories and checking them.
However,
it's not surprising to me that someone
had a thought a few thousand years ago,
which turns out to be in accord with
what we discover.
Where I would disagree is I don't think
that they had those thoughts by some
royal road to the truth or something.
I don't think that.
I think that they.
So let's say these.
You say in some context a religious
context or theological context.
Few thousand years ago,
we think for the sake of argument in the
Koran,
no,
put it back in that gates of Ellis Larry
say we say we think that we live in an
expanding universe.
So we think there's points of light in
the sky or other worlds as,
as people did say,
and we think they're all rushing away
from each from us.
Right?
And then,
uh,
so,
well,
certainly for the galaxies,
this is true.
So the fact that someone said that it's
something you could imagine saying,
you can imagine looking at those points
of light in dreaming,
that there are other worlds.
And actually Giordano Bruno famously did
that and got burned at the stake in Rome
in and his ashes thrown into the Tiber.
I think as part of the new year's
celebrations that could very well that
grow and expand across the Tiber
limitless particles because he said that
he said,
I think these are the worlds and,
and wells without end limitless.
And now he had no reason to say that.
It was pure thought,
but it's something that you could
imagine someone saying very politically
now.
It turned out to be right,
but I don't think that.
I think the fact that he was right,
it was coincidental.
I don't think he had some path route to
knowledge through meditation.
The other thing,
there is a route to knowledge of nature
through meditation.
There may well be.
I'm sure there is a route to inner peace
and a better understanding of yourself
and your relationship with nature,
but I would.
I do not think that you can find out a.
You could build new physical theories
by,
by meditating,
by meditating alone.
Everybody thinking.
I mean I have to just crap when someone
has a flash of intuition or inspiration,
all these things and all this
inflammation is entering the world
through people's consciousness check it
is by doing science.
Definitely check it through science yet
and I was just dreaming about something.
I refuse to check it and that is wrong.
That sort of like,
you know,
like I think from whatever angle you
approach it,
when you get into Dogma and doctrine and
telling people what to do and what they
can be and what they can't be.
I think you get into really dicey
territory from my perspective,
where the bias is is has gone towards
sort of science,
particularly economics and particularly
political science.
Like what I'll watch your programs,
I'll watch you talk about the way that
was is behaving and pebbles in lakes and
the life of strawberries of me.
This is awesome and beautiful and
glorious and precisely what we need to
examine and track,
but what I feel is is somehow the same
way as the,
you know,
one could say the philosophy of Christ
was used to underwrite a great big,
powerful economic institution that ends
up saying,
don't put back there.
It will revisit v people for Anatomy is
you know,
the people use science to say don't
think that live there a bay these rules,
and this is this.
You're right,
that this is entirely wrong because
science science is a body of knowledge.
It doesn't tell you anything really.
It doesn't tell you anything about how
to,
what to make of that knowledge.
And when it can tell you there are 2
trillion in the observable
universe,
full stop.
It doesn't tell you what that means,
right?
What,
what do you to make it that doesn't tell
you it's the same with,
and we're going to go back to
oppenheimer,
you know,
the idea that so you can build an atomic
bomb and science tells you,
it gives you the knowledge so that you
can build an atomic bomb.
It certainly does not tell you what to
do with it right now.
I mean,
actually we would argue that common
sense tells you not to use it.
Don't press that button.
It's.
But um,
so I think that's a key point.
So for me,
the,
the proper interaction between science
and religion and philosophy and theology
and art and music and literature.
All this data is that they go together
to allow us to build a,
a view of what our place in the universe
is and what it means to be human.
None of them on the own will allow you
to build that idea,
to come to that conclusion.
What does it mean to be human?
But you need them all for so beautiful,
isn't it?
Thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis that you have to come
together.
And that means that one of the things
that you've mentioned a lot,
Bryan,
is humility that that there needs to be
humility in all these communities and in
a sense,
an idea of an objective,
like you said,
about sort of a with the libertarianism
ultimate individualism,
communism,
so of aversion of the subjugation of the
individual in favor of the state.
We have to,
in order to build systems,
human systems that make sense to us is
going to need to be a collaboration
between science,
spirituality,
our theology,
and all these taxonomies are
interchangeable.
Because one man spirituality is another
man's science night.
I recognize that what you're saying is
on the bandwidth of material energy that
can be measured,
magnified,
shrunk,
weighed out,
double blind,
tested.
There are certain things that we can say
on this plane of factual at this time,
at this moment,
on this level.
I think the crisis that we're going
through at the moment that a
civilization is.
We don't have a point.
There isn't a meaning to our
civilization and I just made a program a
while ago about commercial spaceflight
until it's people like Elon Musk and
Jeff Bezos and the these entrepreneurs
who were trying to go out beyond the
earth and they all share a philosophy,
a certain philosophy,
which is that humanity,
if you're looking for meaning what
drives us,
we need frontiers,
frontiers of knowledge there,
which you might call intellectual or
spiritual frontiers and physical from
tears.
We need somewhere to go.
Carl Sagan once said that somewhere out
there,
there's something waiting to be known in
her.
Beautiful.
And uh,
so,
so we,
we,
we don't have that on the earth anymore.
There are no frontiers rather obviously
both political borders,
but there are no places that we haven't
been.
There's no wild west push into.
And so they think that the next step to
go out upwards to the stars to step onto
the moon and to Mars.
And beyond that,
the place where
our,
where we will find meaning again.
Well I hope possibly there.
Right?
And it's certainly very intrepid,
but I would query the idea that we are
without frontiers because there are
certain ideological and physical spaces
that we have not tried to access.
We have not here on what value is it?
If we start building new societies on
Mars,
if down here on bloody earth,
we're treating each other appallingly.
There are basic principles that have
found their way into common
consciousness,
mostly for spirituality with long,
long,
long before monotheism pantheistic
cultures.
All find versions of look after one
another.
That's not to say there isn't a you and
you would know much more than me,
kind of brutality in nature,
whether it's zoology or astronomy,
there's a brutality and a finality,
but are these the principles that we
want to be governed by human beings?
For the frontiers,
I would be interested in traversing and
heading toward a quality love new
systems that give us,
once again a vision so that the
exploration of space becomes valid but
not once again,
the pursuit of economic power,
the pursue of dominions,
dominions new.
We've conquered and subjugated mother
earth.
They see what other planets we can fuck
up.
One of the,
one of the ideas is that how do you
develop new political systems?
So if you look at,
for example,
the uh,
America,
so,
so the,
the,
the movement from Europe into America
and that ended up with the American
constitution.
And so there,
there are obviously there were pros and
cons of this steady Brian Slavery,
but you got to sign,
one of the things you got was this
document which I think is widely
recognized as one of the,
the,
the most important statements of how you
might send nice poems,
but if it doesn't relate to the way you
run a society,
then what value is it?
And this is precisely the problem now
which is not put it into practice if you
grow.
And even then Brian,
it was except for these people,
you know,
except for women except for these people
that live here already.
But the point is that no,
this certainly there is a relationship
between the physical and the spiritual.
The,
if we grow into new territory is
physically there is a possibility that
will somehow help us to discover within
ourselves new notions.
But like we can do that without getting
on a spaceship,
we could just start saying that's not
judge people couldn't what they look
like or some of the ideas is that our
system on this planet now it's become
quite ossified.
What's that mean?
Not Fossil and locked in.
Whereas if you go to,
if you imagine that in a hundred years'
time or something we have the Mars
colony is,
is looking to become independent and
the,
the act of going to a new place and
beginning again can allow you to access
different ways of being in different
ways of interacting that might not be
possible here because of the historic
borders and,
and,
and problems they may have.
I sort of agree,
but that doesn't make me want to get on
a spaceship that makes people want to
get on the barricade.
It makes me want to change the world.
It makes me say if we've reached a sort
of a point of crisis,
like for me it's not like,
oh bloody hell,
let's go somewhere else.
For me it's like we're going to have to
change.
You will know that the one area where
science is not being allowed to a,
not the one,
but I an area where science is not being
allowed to inform the way we treat the
planet is with climate change.
People are not going right steady
because for me,
one of the things I've learned over the
course of this podcast,
and I must say this,
one of the ones that have been like a
great big iceberg of inflammation,
smashing into my consciousness.
Hopefully I can stay afloat,
unlikely every other vessel in that
analogy is that,
um,
is the,
all our ideologies are caveated by.
And as long as it doesn't affect the
interest of the powerful,
we must do something about climate
change.
As long as it doesn't affect the
interest of the powerful,
we must have says as long as it doesn't
impact later.
So for me,
it's about finding ways of impact the
interests of the powerful.
Until we are prepared to do that and to
ever better address that frontier is no
point in jumping on Elan Musk space
craft or saying,
yeah,
perhaps it is a virtual reality
experiment.
We have to start saying,
what is happening?
These people are behaving in this way.
Right?
Well,
that's got to be regulated and stopped
and stripped.
You're right.
I mean,
interesting that Jeff Bezos,
the Amazon Ceo,
who's got a company blue origin,
and he said to me,
first of all,
why is this company called blue origin?
Because it refers to the earth,
the blue origin of humanity,
and he said that the one thing we've
learned in our exploration of the solar
system and beyond is that this planet is
the best one,
right?
We've learned that number one,
and that means that is a jewel.
He calls it a jewel of a planet and
therefore we must protect it.
At the same time,
we have a large population which is
making increase in depends on the
resources.
So what is the solution?
How do you support an expanding
population,
all of whom want a better life for them
and their children at the same time is
protecting this beautiful blue planet.
The answer is to get the resources from
elsewhere.
That's the answer.
Answer.
Another one would be to start
prioritizing the health of the planet
above economic needs.
As long as you've got a capitalism,
uh,
in the form,
it's now way in which many people would
argue is way beyond capitalism.
Then then it's inevitable.
And what Marx is critical theory that
the first discovery page one is this is
a limited resource we are.
It cannot provide limited growth.
So that's got to go there.
May well have a,
you can argue that you have a point in,
in Europe,
North America and the West that you
might call,
but if you talk about sub Saharan Africa
or India or large parts of China,
than it is difficult to see how you can
lift those people out of poverty at the
same time.
That reducing the demand on the planet
because those people are there and they
live in poverty and it's right that they
aspire to a better life for their
children.
But the,
the,
the answer can,
can be innovation.
I mean,
for example,
I was in China about two weeks ago and
they just canceled the building of 150
coal fired power stations.
Canceled it and the reason they
cancelled it was because solar power is
cheaper,
so it was purely,
it was partly market driven decision,
partly because they have a problem with
pollution in the cities,
but the point is the innovation has
delivered a solution because solar power
makes no impact on the planet.
It's too shuffle.
So like once you know that wisdom is
acting on knowledge,
once we have that,
the facts just in the next thing should
be around a phone calls like,
Hey,
guess what?
Now solar power only as quickly as
possible.
Now.
Whose interests do you challenge when
you make that edict?
So?
Well,
actually I've got side very quickly.
I know you've got to stop.
I guess where I'm going.
I'm literally going to church.
I do know I was talking to Brian Cox
early to do in the book,
but there's a guy who sat next to me on
the panel and he was in Hong Kong,
a property developer and he said,
uh,
the,
one of the things about China that,
that's rather,
which is good,
is the,
the,
the interests that,
those fossil fuel interests that those
big companies,
it doesn't,
it doesn't exist in China.
The ruling party make the decision.
They made the decision based on we don't
want pollution,
we want less pollution.
Could it's killing our people and we
want cheap,
accessible power that is solar.
So immediately I will draw a line
through 105th,
the contract for 150 coal fired power
stations and I'll change it to solar
panels.
Done.
And,
and he said,
he,
he argued,
I do obviously counter arguments,
but he argued that that's why he said to
me,
that's why China will beat you,
beat you,
because we will make decisions like
that.
Now we could debate that.
But it's interesting.
And one thing that's always is distinct
is that China,
it comes from a different philosophical
tradition,
has a completely different Veltin Sean,
so he's able to make decisions like
that,
not just because of Maoism and post
communism,
but because of the philosophies that
proceeded it.
Brown,
I said just because when people are
listening,
I know that there are big problems with
human rights.
I was thinking I'm not waving the flag
for the Chinese system and there are
systems within which those interests
matter a lot less.
Yes,
there are,
there are.
And that's what is interesting to me.
What I feel Brian Cox is that you have
been kind of I in my language,
I profit and an educator and a Swami for
such valuable beautiful information.
And who knows what the future holds for
me,
you know,
you get my vote on the next David
attenborough deal.
Like,
I mean,
like I,
I see he was very much the human voice
of science.
But for me,
like as you have indicated,
there needs to be many voices in the
human conversation for us to have a
chance.
And,
uh,
once again,
what I feel like is that there is much
to learn from the realms that can never
be empirically demonstrated.
And now like I know that sounds quite
high minded by simply talking about love
and kindness and the ability for
ordinary people for,
to have their needs met and to have
impact on the power Sagan said,
for small creatures such as we,
the vastness is variable only through
love.
Oh right.
Carl Sagan.
That's given to us.
Where Brian Cox,
I want you to on record,
make a commitment to come back and be
interviewed again.
Would you do that?
Yes.
Whenever you want.
I enjoyed it very much.
I will be back tomorrow with you on.
I really loved it.
Might get intense because we're coming
at things from quite different
impositions,
but I absolutely adore you and I'm very
grateful to you for the education.
Thank you.
I've enjoyed it very much.
Thanks man.
Cheers.